I don't know I was stalling for time all
right
I really understand why was this is the
last Evo up it was Matt Morey I mean now
you really get it that was probably the
worst grand finals in Evo history from
the audience it looked like two friends
making a mockery of the biggest
tournament of the year but if you knew
the backstory you knew that it was the
culmination of the years of a hate being
thrown at those two players but not
because they talked trash or because
they were community villains they were
hated because they played a Bayonetta
you're making is easy
they picked a top tier because they
wanted to win instead their character
toward the community apart
[Music]
Bayonetta is arguably the most hated
character in any smash game but the
irony is that fans actually voted for
her to be in the game we've been asking
for your opinion on the Super Smash
Brothers fighter ballot and Bayonetta
was the overall number one choice
worldwide a few months after winning the
vote Bayonetta finally arrived in Smash
and people were pretty excited No
[Music]
[Applause]
but that excitement was quickly replaced
with horror as the community realizes
just what the character was capable of
[Applause]
did you guys see that you guys see that
it looks like the shift in power is
coming back into zeros corner even with
all this ridiculous shield pressure Wow
check out my feet oh my god Danny goes
up the brink of jet Beynon has shot up
to the top of pretty much everyone smash
for cheerless it was clear very early on
that she was broken he picked it up on
release played it for a few days and
then proceeded to beat everyone in Japan
a huge tournament yeah sure the player
amazing but no character in the whole
series has ever been that easy and
successful tool early hip hop in a few
days and played at a tournament of that
caliber and just win like that smash 4
had already seen its fair share of
powerful top-tier characters but
Bayonetta was a cut above she was fast
an incredible recovery and per unique
mechanic which time made it extremely
risky to actually attack her but what
made Bayonetta truly broken was that she
had a OneTouch kill combo from pretty
much anywhere on screen
she had amazing offense and defense and
could confirm her kill combos from
almost anywhere on screen she had almost
no weaknesses my opinion Bayonetta
carries players she's very easy to use
and if you execute everything properly
the opponent just can't escape anything
so everyone hated Bane it up pretty much
instantly but that didn't stop anyone
from playing her from pros to casuals
everyone wanted the free win so they
picked Bayonetta I don't know why people
are so mad about Bayonetta look I paid
$5.99 I practiced for a week I deserve
to be rewarded for my dedication
Bayonetta was clearly too strong so
Nintendo hit her with the nerf hammer in
2016 and for awhile people thought these
nerfs actually worked we saw a very big
nerf coming to being that actually
within the recent patches and a lot of
people actually drop her from being
possibly or the best crack in the game
to sometimes even saying that she's not
even top 10 or top 20 like that was the
quieter that was the level of change of
a pain that some people had regarding
Bayonetta in the end the nurse didn't
really amount to much sure it was harder
for a casual player to see her to death
you but pros can still kill you for
breathing in their general direction she
was still the best character in the game
and no one else could really compete oh
[Music]
yeah that character is just ridiculous
sometimes fast forward to 2018 a year
and a half after her last nerf and
Bayonetta was still dominating
tournaments the patches had a long since
dogged there was no more hope for
further nerves
players were so frustrated by Bayonetta
that some regions even considered
banning her and while that didn't
necessarily amount to much people still
needed to get their rage out [ __ ]
hate this character and who better to
take their rage out on than Bayonetta
players and like during tournaments
itself you get people in the crowd or or
in the stands you know not definitely
cheering for the other character that's
not painted uh happen happens a lot
I've been interments where I've seen you
know people lost equals hands they take
you know God co2 deaths by baby I
already got mad it didn't matter if you
were new to the scene or an established
Pro anyone who picked Bayonetta got
slammed and what a catch captain Zack
look if you got to be the villain you
might as well play the part row it seems
ridiculous from the outside looking in
but it really did happen in most scenes
picking a top tier is just how you win
but there were a ton of factors at work
between declining viewership and lower
character diversity Bayonetta players
were scapegoats and people took their
rage out on them Salem was one he got
all the way to Grand Finals using
Bayonetta a lot of people saying he's
carried by his character Bayonetta
stupid nairo and de buzz only got 1317
this is [ __ ] how was this guy
winning I don't know how many of you
guys know brawl history because if I've
learned anything in the past month of
casting it's that a lot of people don't
know what happened in brawl Salem has
won an apex you guys know that right an
international event featuring hundreds
of players the best players in the world
and as Bayonetta mains kept picking up
top placements the community revved up
their hate engine more and more and at
Evo 2018 that hate reached its peak
[Music]
Yury right now so with the foul they
play a little fire theory as well both
and Kaleo and tweek two of the best
players in the world couldn't attend
Devo that year which left the tournament
with no clear favorite well there was
one favorite Bayonetta
wonders Venice will be hitting the
losers bracket one of these will face
off against captain Zach so yet another
Bayonetta did over the winners finals
we'll find out who it is right here
right now there were three bayonetta's
in top eight at Evo that year and two of
them made it to the grand finals captain
Zach versus Alima Bayonetta versus
Bayonetta it was a match that almost no
fan wanted to watch and it was enough
reason for most of them to just tune out
there's always some boos but most of the
people that would boot left a crowd kind
of bundled down after that happen
19:00 that happened after after that was
decided for for evo from the start the
grand final seemed a little bit off see
the players were just kind of joking
around with each other between games it
looked more like a friendly you'd see at
a local than the grand finals of the
biggest tournament in the world when
captain Zack accidentally
self-destructed Lima gave him a homey
stock he lost a stop on purpose instead
of taking the advantage in Grand Finals
at Evo all right so you know how I feel
that homey stocks right here Lima can
just play hard get the win and no one
gives him even 1% of the [ __ ] they got
for what happened if he just played it
out right here and just played it in one
the people would you know they would
they would moan about bayonetta but
doubt but you know they don't they
always moan about Bayonetta it would
just be another tournament but the fact
that Lima went for the homey stock here
is kind of a pocketbook again this whole
disaster but for the most part they were
actually playing the game until this
happened
[Music]
all right I really understand why this
is the last Evo up Cory I mean that you
really they just sat there charging
Bayonetta's bullets and doing nothing
for almost two minutes the only reason
they even started to play again was cuz
bear one of Evo's TOS stepped in to save
the day so basically they held the beep
on down and then they didn't move and
then the rules are if you're stalling
and you don't continue to match after
being warned they were both gotten
disqualified so that was the first
yellow card I actually gave Anna
tournament setting were like it and I
explained to them after is like you
that's actually stalling it's against
the rules for for all games at Evo and
that they continue to this high warning
that the letter would have been the
first I got third place to say this
match for community was unhappy with his
grand finals was an understatement they
were furious bro imagine if I did that
oh I did that in May like me and I don't
know me and you - King I guess oh dude
what would have happened already gunshot
I think I wouldn't be here right now you
can see it's just a dumb stunt done by
two teenagers who have since grown up
and learned from their mistakes but that
didn't stop people from going in people
accuse them of ruining evo which was
smash bores biggest and arguably last
major tournament before getting replaced
by its successor in many people's minds
smash pours time in the mainstream
spotlight ended with that grand finals
which meant that for most people
Bayonetta ruined the game's legacy as
the years went on many of the
high-profile Baena domains retired from
competitive smash it wasn't just that
smash 4 was dying it was that they
couldn't handle the hate that came with
picking Bayonetta in just a few months
after evo Nintendo released Super Smash
Bros ultimate effectively killing smash
4 forever
Iannetta is not the same terror she was
in Smash for Nintendo learned their
lesson and rained
she's a shadow of her former self and
brings up the lower-middle of most here
lists but Bayonetta will forever have
her place in the pantheon of broken
smash characters she destroyed an entire
game but more importantly she almost
ruined the lives of the people who
played her and no amount of nerfs can
ever undo that kind of damage thanks for
watching if you want more content like
this hit the sub button and ring that
notification bell for unique bite-sized
videos you will find anywhere else hit
up our Instagram Twitter and Facebook
pages
[Music]